When you're installing an operating
system, you often have a choice. You can
upgrade or you can install. Upgrade
means that you already have an operating
system in place and you'd like to keep
all of your applications and all of your
files exactly where they are and then
simply update the operating system
around them. Installing means you're
effectively starting over completely
fresh. So, if you have any data on that
drive, you're going to delete all of
that and perform a fresh installation.
Upgrading may be a good choice if you
have many different local user accounts
on this system, which means many
different people are using this
computer, or you may have some
specialized configurations and you don't
want to lose those configs. By simply
upgrading, you're leaving your
configurations in place and all of your
user accounts and you're simply
upgrading the operating system files
associated with that computer. This can
obviously save you a lot of time. You
don't have to reinstall any
applications. This also keeps all of
your user data in place, so you don't
have to back up everything and then
restore it after you're done. This keeps
all of your user settings, so all of the
configurations that you've created for
your user account on that system. And
that ultimately means that upgrading
will probably be a much faster way to
get that operating system up to date.
It's important that you understand the
differences between an in place upgrade
and a clean install. Neither one is
better than the other, but you should
use the right one for your specific
circumstance. An in place upgrade will
upgrade the existing operating system,
but keep everything in place on your
system. The applications, the documents,
and the settings all remain the same.
It's common to start an in place upgrade
by launching the installation process
from inside of the existing OS. This is
compared to a clean install which wipes
everything on that system. All of the
applications, all of the user data, and
all of the existing operating system
files. Everything is removed, and you're
installing it as if it is a brand new
installation. If you're planning this
route, it's always a good idea to back
up everything that's on the system
already. People will tell you, "Yes, you
can delete everything on that computer."
And then when you delete it, they'll
realize, "Oh, wait. There's this one
file I need." If you have a backup, you
can recover that information relatively
easy, even though you did a clean
install. You would normally begin a
clean install from the boot process of
your computer by booting from the
installation media. Before you begin the
installation, it's always a good idea to
check the drive you're performing the
installation on. Is there any data on
that drive currently? Has the drive
recently been formatted? You might also
want to check to see if there's any
other partitions on this drive that
maybe the user is not currently aware
of. And as we've already mentioned, once
you repartition and reformat that drive,
it's very difficult, if not impossible,
to recover that data. So, it's always a
good idea to get a backup even if the
user thinks that perhaps they won't need
any of this data in the future. By
taking that backup, you can now recover
if anybody needs any of this data in the
future. It might also be a good idea to
save any user preferences so that when
the system is restarted, you might be
able to copy those back over to the
appropriate application. Usually, you
don't need a third party application to
do any type of partitioning or
formatting of the drive because those
features are usually built into the
installation process itself. You're able
to start the install, clear out any
existing partitions, or reformat over
the partitions that currently
exist. If you're moving from one
operating system version to another, it
might be a good idea to check the
requirements for that OS. Check to see
that your system has enough memory, has
enough spare drive space, and is able to
support all of the features of that new
operating system. There's usually a list
of recommended requirements in the
operating system documentation.
Microsoft includes a nice hardware
compatibility check that you can run to
see if your system can support the
version of Windows that you'd like to
install. You would usually run this
before performing the upgrade and you'd
get all the feedback you need on whether
this system can support the new
operating system or if you need to
improve some of those resources. For
Windows 11, Microsoft refers to this
application as the PC health check for
Windows 11. You also might want to make
sure that you have an answer to any of
these questions that commonly appear
during the installation process. For
example, you need to know what drive
you're going to install this operating
system on, what type of configuration
you're going to use for the partitions,
and you might also want to have any
necessary license keys available for the
installation process. Sometimes you'll
find that certain applications or
certain device drivers will not be
compatible in the newer version of the
operating system. So, check the
documentation from all of your app
developers and check the details of all
of your device drivers and make sure
they're compatible with the new version
of the operating system that you're
installing. Here's the PC health check
program for Windows 11. And it tells you
what your system is currently configured
with. And it says introducing Windows
11. And we can click the check now
button to see if it meets the system
requirements. This takes a few minutes
to run. And on this computer, PC health
check tells us this PC doesn't currently
meet the Windows 11 system requirements.
Then it gives you a list of the things
that do and don't meet the requirements.
It says that this PC must support secure
boot. TPM2.0 must be supported and
enabled on this PC. Neither one of those
meets the minimum requirements of
Windows 11. This system does meet the
requirements for the processor. tells us
that the processor is supported for
Windows 11 and there is enough memory in
the system to be able to run Windows
11. Most operating system manufacturers
will give you a life cycle calendar.
This will tell you when this operating
system is in support and when this
operating system will be retired from
support. This life cycle usually starts
with quality updates where you get
monthly security updates, monthly bug
fixes, and it keeps the system updated
every month of the year. You might also
get feature updates. These are usually
released with new capabilities in the
operating system and these are often
updated every 6 months or every year. We
usually see most operating systems
supported anywhere from 18 to 36 months.
And this will depend on the type of
Windows operating system and the version
that you happen to be using. If you'd
like more information on the Windows
product life cycle, Microsoft refers to
this as the modern life cycle policy.
And all of these details are available
on the Microsoft
website. As we've seen, there may be
cases where you can't simply install
Windows 11 on a machine that's currently
running Windows 10. You might want to
look at the additional requirements and
know exactly what you might want to
change to be able to upgrade this
system. One of the big requirements for
Windows 11 is that you have a TPM, a
trusted platform module. This is usually
hardware on the motherboard of this
system, and it has to be compatible with
a more recent version of TPM,
specifically TPM 2.0 or later. This is
cryptographic hardware, and it's
important to use this for Bit Locker,
Windows Hello, and a number of other
Windows features. If you'd like to check
the details of your TPM, you can run the
TPM. MSC. This is the Microsoft snap-in
for the Microsoft management console
that gives you all of the details about
the TPM that's in your
system. Windows 11 also requires a
modern version of a BIOS, specifically
the UEFI BIOS. It's one that provides
capabilities for secure boot and Windows
11 requires secure boot to operate. You
can check the status of secure boot on
your system by running the system
information utility and check in the
section titled system summary. If you
have a much older computer, you may find
that it does not have a UEFI BIOS and
you may need to physically replace that
computer in order to support Windows 11.
This is the Windows system information
utility. And under the system summary
section, there are a lot of details. And
the one you're looking for is the one
that says secure boot state. And
ideally, it should be turned on. Once
you check the requirements for your
operating system and your applications,
you'll be ready to upgrade to the latest
version of Windows.